despite booking a spot in the fa cup
quarterfinals there was a somber look on
the faces of chelsea's players on
wednesday night
that's because behind the scenes the
blues are facing their most uncertain
period in recent history
[Applause]
before their match chelsea owner russian
billionaire roman abramovich announced
he plans to sell the club the 55 year
old's ownership has become complicated
by russia's invasion of ukraine
some have called for him to face
sanctions
abramovic has already given stewardship
and care of chelsea to club trustees
very sad day
for us
rome has taken
taken the club so far and the club have
done so much
you know under his watch um so
you know it is what is what it is and as
players we have to carry on and and be
professional it's the best part it's a
super part they've stopped right there
chelsea have become one of the giants of
club football since abramovic took over
in 2003.
since then they've won five premier
league titles five fa cups and the
champions league twice
they were also recently crowned world
club champions
once the club is sold keeping up these
standards won't be easy
but they will need money spent on them
because that money has been put in by a
branch over the course of 20 years uh
you know that they're running a loss
every year and that's been covered by
abramovich and a new new owner will have
to be prepared to put to inject new
money into the club
potential buyers have already begun to
surface
swiss billionaire hans yorkvis says he's
been approached to purchase the london
team
there's even been interest from the
world's biggest mma star conor mcgregor
whoever takes over they'll need deep
pockets with abramovich looking for more
than 4 billion
chelsea fans will be hoping the
situation can be resolved soon and the
new owner will continue to help the team
win trophies suhail malik al jazeera